I think people are generally tired of
having the rainbow flag shoved down
their face and their children's faces
all day every day it struck me how much
of a ubiquitous fact of American life it
is just you walk around even when it's
not June every ad every storefront it
gets that green grocer sort of situation
where everyone just puts it in the
window because they're afraid of what it
means if they don't and I think there is
some softening on
the general support uh for
perhaps gay marriage although I don't
know if there's a way to draw a direct
line between those two things I think
people are just sort of sick of the
advancement of the Rainbow Coalition to
the top of every conversation I do think
it's a sort of leave me alone impulse
like I don't want to deal with it
anymore it's gotten to this very extreme
point where it's become controversial to
say that people with penises are men and
people with vaginas or woman women right
so I think people are just just very fed
up with it